next question is from Naomi Naomi says
hey David what do you think the future
of Republicans like John McCain Jeff
Flake and bob corker is in the world of
Trump and the alt-right I think that
they are an endangered species
I think that increasingly those
individuals we have a very corporate
moderate Democratic Party right now so
once you start to compare yourself as a
moderate Republican to the alt-right
crazies you probably are more in line
with simpatico with the more
conservative or moderate Democrats than
you are with the extreme all try ters
yeah and I don't know I'm not suggesting
that people like Jeff Flake are going to
eventually become Democrats that that's
not actually what I'm saying but what I
do believe is that you are going to see
a Democratic Party that will have to
decide are we moving to the left and
more in the direction of Bernie or are
we going to sort of coalesce around we
are corporate Dems like joe Manchin for
example or and then on the Republican
side you will see the decision made
manat like people will sit down and make
the decision are we going to be the
party of people like Donald Trump and
the alt-right or are we going to go back
to being the party of people like John
McCain and I don't know what the answer
is it does feel like there are for
political parties now I mean on the far
right you have the alt-right types you
have the Bannen wing really more and
Donald Trump and then you have the more
reasonable Republicans John McCain Jeff
Flake bob Corker this goes on Susan
Collins maybe sure yeah and then you
have the corporate Democrats the Hillary
Clinton joe Manchin's and you have the
left wing of the party like Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren I agree
with your analysis
except that although I believe Donald
Trump has coalesced this extreme right
all right thing I don't think he's
actually part of it I think Trump really
has no political philosophy I think the
guy's just a [ __ ] and he'll do whatever
it is he thinks he needs to do to gain
an advantage at the time so while I
believe Trump is responsible in part for
this split between the Jeff Flake types
and the outright I actually think Trump
is outside of this altogether he's in
the I'll go with someone told me five
minutes ago that I think will help me
win a lot yeah I think
along with your assessment there because
he did endorse Luther strange in Alabama
never Roy Moore who was the lesser live
lineup would write a little bit more was
Lucy a strange not as much of like an
evangelical a little bit more sane yeah
no more actual assault allegations made
against him that I know if that were
aware of yeah so I think that that's the
direction Naomi that it's going to go
you you are going to see maybe a
strengthening of the middle of the
corporate middle with more conservative
Dems and more moderate Republicans and
that could become the mainstream
Republican Party or it might get pushed
out if the alt-right becomes the sort of
dominant Republican Party going forward